hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Doctor Who Q&A a lot of good
new Missy Danny pink theories I also
wanted to add that Ellis George was seen
in the teaser for episode 7 so we will
be seeing her in that episode I tried to
see if she was listed in the cast for
any of the future episodes after that
but I couldn't find her so she could
show up again after episode 7 all had
new information if something changes
they did cast some really interesting
people for the rest of those episodes
episodes 8 through the finale I'll just
talk about them whenever they get here
and really good news to the Doctor Who
legacy people the people behind the
video game reached out to me about doing
a special giveaway for episode 7 so be
sure to subscribe to get that video
it'll start on saturday i'll explain the
rest at the end of this video time for
questions though so careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet I'll wait just a sec okay here we go
question number one Tasman devil asks
will there be more Courtney woods in the
future and do you think that she'll die
and go to Missy so I already answered
the first part to that I think the
second part of your question is really
interesting though moffatts the writer
and he's probably gonna go for a maximum
cry level killing a child feels just a
little too cruel though even for him I
know there have been times during
classic who when children died but just
going on moffatts own personal history I
think he'd be more likely that he kill
an adult beloved character something
about killing a child just makes it feel
like it's something that BBC would not
want him to do number two dragonfly noir
asks do you agree with the criticism
that doctor who this season has been too
similar to Sherlock I haven't seen a lot
of sentiment like that on the videos
that I've been posting so I assume
you're talking about professional
critics I noticed a lot of sherlocky
things in the premiere but I think
that's because vostro scare achter has
always been linked to Sherlock Holmes I
think any connection to Benedict
Cumberbatch's Sherlock series is just a
coincidence yes there are Sherlock
overtones and Moffat is in charge of
both series but I think when we've seen
them they've been endemic to the
characters like it's been inappropriate
ways if they played the BBC Sherlock
theme in the background that would be
way too much of course at that point I
would say you know enough is enough
number three Andrew asks what was the
bit about the planet in the beginning
about the montage was just all about
Clara running from adventure to advance
between time with Danny like she's
constantly jumping in and out of the
TARDIS I'm not sure what planet they
were on but if anyone thinks they know
just write in the comments below they
also visited fish people in a bunch of
other places it just gives you a sense
for the sheer quantity of stories
happening that we never get to witness
like we only see the doctor for about 50
minutes a week which comprises a single
adventure but outside of that he could
be going on hundreds of other adventures
that's really where tumblr fan fiction
in the expanded material picks things up
number 4 Alex Wilcox asks do you think
that Danny and Clara will get married
and they'll use that as an excuse if
Jenna Coleman leaves the show I
definitely think they're pushing us in
that direction I don't think it's gonna
be really clean cut like that though I
don't think it's going to end that way
there have been a lot of romantic
companions that have gotten pseudo happy
endings like Amy got Rory Rose got a
version of the doctor I think Moffat
might be setting us up for a huge twist
though like he'll make everyone really
happy and comfortable with the idea of
Clara getting married and then all of a
sudden he'll just yank the rug out from
under us it just feels like a very TV
thing to do like a TV trope make you
love a character then kill him off I
don't know that it'll go down that way
but I think that when she does leave
she'll get her happy ending but she's
gonna have to endure a lot of pain to
get it number 5 chris paul asks what do
you think the best episode so far is
right now it's listen but based on what
the Doctor Who people and other bloggers
are saying about the next episode kill
the moon I'm thinking that's going to
end up being the fan favorite so I'm
really excited to see it number 6 drew
asks what do you think the policeman saw
through the window at the end so when
Yuri watch the episode at the end you
can see chris addison you know really
excited to show this policeman his new
environment but the policeman looks like
you know he has this sheer look of
horror on his face it's like he's
completely in shock not the kind of
shocked you'd see on someone's face
Christmas morning opening gifts like the
kind of shocked you see on someone's
face when they're told they have cancer
something about what he saw
fundamentally changed his core belief
system it's like Oswin Oswald realizing
she had been turned into a Dalek that's
genuine horror I know there have been
some spoilery things about the finale so
I'm not going to mention those and
please use spoiler tags if you're going
to comment on
question number 7 a person asks hello a
person I am also a person what's with
all the moffat shared writing credits
this season so I've heard a lot of
rumors about drama behind the scenes in
the production offices I don't know if
any of that's true I think it's mostly
because of the way they structured story
is this season they're making things
less they realized but they still have
to service the overarching plots like
Missy and Danny pink with Clara part of
moffatts role as showrunner is just to
make sure that they don't lose sight of
those things so he probably jumped on a
lot of these scripts just to make sure
they tied in with the things that we're
going to see happening in the finale so
that by the end everything makes sense
I'm sure he does a lot of other minor
edits on all the stories but in general
adding a writing credit for himself to a
script means he wrote a significant
portion of it himself and obviously
those significant portions I think are
just things that are important for the
finale number eight why not asks I
missed the big epic moments that Matt
Smith got do you think we'll get some of
those this year part of the reason why
he got those is because Matt Smith's run
was much more serialize so they had much
more time to build up to those big big
payoff moments yes I do think we're
gonna get some major Capaldi moments but
I don't think we'll see those till much
later in the series episode 7 is
supposed to be pretty epic bloggers are
saying it's going to change the course
of the series so I guess you could view
that is like one of those big epic Matt
Smith episodes number nine Colin daily
asks do you think Danny pink being on
the TARDIS this year will cause the
doctor to go darker and become the
valued I actually think that the doctor
is gonna warm up to Danny I feel like
it's one of those big setup things where
muffets gonna yank the rug out from
under us at the end I don't think he's
gonna warm up to Danny as much as the
eleventh Doctor warm data Rory but he's
going to get as warm as a grumpy old
Scottish doctor can get trust is a big
theme this year so it makes sense that
the doctor and Danny would start to
trust each other right as that trust
gets broken in a big way asked for the
value though no I don't think that he's
gonna be turning into the valued number
10 mr. nobody asks what does Ozzy love
the squatty mean I actually had to
rewatch the episode because I didn't get
the reference right away but it's
basically Oswalt loves the squaddie it's
just shorthand for Clara loves Danny
Ozzy as in Oswald and squatty just a
reference to military squadron
Clara and Annie had this moment early in
the episode where car asked Danny if the
girls outside including Courtney there
know about the two of them dating Danny
said possibly their children they've got
minds of their own I kind of think it
just says something about the way the
Doctor Who writers view the intelligence
of children like children are much more
perceptive than adults maybe we'll see
that play out with the Courtney
character in episode 7 I don't think
they'd include her in the episode if she
wasn't going to be a big part of the
plot thank you so much everyone for
submitting questions these are always a
ton of fun to do and congratulations to
super duck you are this week's giveaway
winner you win an amazon gift card i'll
just be reaching out to you on your
channel for details so and here's the
details on that Doctor Who legacy
giveaway so the people working at the
mobile game reached out to me just about
giving you guys a general big giveaway
so it's going to be a gift code that
everyone's going to be able to use it's
not going to be like a contest or
anything like literally everyone will be
able to use it i'll be releasing it
whenever I post my episode 7 video so
that will start on Saturday and it'll
run for about 30 days like you'll be
able to use that code for about 30 days
I've got a bunch of videos that I'm
working on in the next couple of days so
I'm trying to get those out as fast as
possible but you can follow me on
Twitter and Facebook if you want to get
more updates about that there's links in
the description but right now you can
click here for my doctor who challenge
video it's just a fun bonus challenge
video and you can click here for my
episode 6 review thank you so much for
watching so that's all high five we'll
meet back up tomorrow to talk about
Gotham
you